ici on a un exemple assez typique par
exemple ici leur saut vous voyez montre
bien que l'eau bien taper dessus
rejaillit sur la pierre unifie la pierre
et toute la partie si basse est en train
de s'offrir pu s'offrir par serge
agissements de la porte de paris est
sans doute le bâtiment le plus
emblématique de la décrépitude des
monuments ne versoix mais cet arc de
triomphe miniature n'est pas le seul à
souffrir des affres du temps une récente
étude a chiffré à plus de 20 millions
d'euros le montant des travaux de
restauration les plus urgents du
patrimoine de la cité ducale un chiffre
qui aurait pu être minimisée par un
suivi périodique qui ont fait de
l'entretien régulier on a estimé on a
fait des études sur ces problèmes là on
estime à cinq fois moins cher le coût de
l'entretien par rapport à des gros
travaux quand on attend de faire des
gros travaux mise en cause par la
nouvelle équipe municipale l'opposition
défense ali politiques de l'époque et
rappelle que la crise est passée par là
il nous a fallu faire des choix et les
choix ont été évidents c'est à dire
priorité aux services publics si nous
avons décidé de ne pas faire des
économies majeures sur les subventions
aux associations c'est parce que nous
pensions et nous pensons encore
aujourd'hui qu'elle assure une mission
de service public c'est la même chose
avec les écoles pour le maire de nevers
il est urgent d'agir mais au vu des
sommes annoncées denis thuriau est bien
conscient qu'il faudra procéder par
étapes et définir des structures
prioritaires comme ce petit théâtre dont
la toiture n'est plus étanche
le tout en diversifiant les sources de
financement rappelle que ce petit
théâtre a été construit à la base grâce
à des dons des neuf et reçoit donc
l'idée c'est de voir les financements
publics que nous aurons nous aurons un
soutien de la drac nous essaierons de
rechercher des fonds européens et puis
aussi le mécénat et pourquoi pas une
contribution des neuf et reçoit s'ils
sont intéressés pour débloquer
rapidement des fonds le premier
magistrat se dit prête à endetter la
ville un choix incompréhensible pour
l'opposition on peut pas comme ça
vraiment d'être se ré endetter la ville
sur des dizaines de millions d'euros
parce que là on vu de 1 des baisses de
dotations et 2 de la réforme
territoriale qui fait que dans quelques
années on ne sait pas le devenir des
communes ou des départements ou des
communautés de communes ça me semblent
se précipiter
ou en tout cas faire un pas dans un vide
que moi je ne souhaite pas que nous
franchissions l'investissement et
l'endettement il faut arrêter d'en avoir
peur celui qui ne s'endette pas qui ne
fait aucuns travaux chez lui au bout de
vingt ans je peux vous dire que là il a
besoin de s'endetter fortement nous
allons faire une politique d'endettement
raisonnée raisonnable les taux d'intérêt
des banques et a fortiori vis-à-vis des
collectivités sont très très bas et si
nous ne le faisions pas nous serions
véritablement irresponsable c'est facile
de dire je ne suis pas endetté mais
quand on ne fait rien mais les suivants
ils ont fort à faire si les cloches de
l'église saint-étienne sont encore elle
pourrait vite s'arrêter les vibrations
qu'elle engendre menace la stabilité
mécanique du clocher preuve que
l'urgence relève tout autant de la
sécurité publique que de l'esthétique